chacun son tour si meringue est aussi
populaire c'est qu'elle est habituée à
être au contact des enfants depuis
plusieurs années la Bergerie nationale
organise ses agré vacances de nombreuses
animations sont proposées tous les jours
durant l'été ici le coin câlin j'aime
bien venir à la ferme parce que j'aime
bien
donner à manger aux animaux et j'aime
bien les caresser et les regarder ça
permet aux familles de rentrer à
l'intérieur de cet espace pour pouvoir
approcher au plus près des animaux
puisque c'est aussi ce qui recherche en
venant ici c'est pouvoir approcher les
animaux et pouvoir les caresser et les
toucher le plus possible piscine de
paille tractocross et découverte de la
ferme en calèche les Jeux d'été se
veulent également ludique nouveuté cette
année une visite sur l'agroécologie pour
sensibiliser les plus jeunes depuis mai
2016 la Bergerie Nationale s'est lancée
dans l'agriculture biologique d'essayer
d'adapter un discours assez compliqué
avec des mots assez compliqués sur
l'agriculture logique de l'adapter à un
public d'enfants donc d'expliquer notre
projet d'établissement qui est un projet
orienté autour de l'agroécologie donc de
l'agriculture durable après avoir
observé les vaches dans les champs
direction la salle de traite et pour les
curieux une dégustation de lait fermier
mais les avis sont partagés c'est
comment c'est pas bon je sais pas c'est
c'est un goût bizarre d'abord les Netto
avec des lingettes et après on les trait
avec des machines c'est bon on
pour ça sent la vache les Jeux d'été de
La Bergerie Nationale continuent
jusqu'au 31 août meringue est prête à
vous
accueillir